tu brûles pas des trucs comme ça moi
aussi j'ai envie de brûler ma
déclaration d'impôts le
bruit
[Applaudissements]
c'est ouais avec liberté égalité
fraternité
maria kaka alors on vous entendez pas ma
chérie on vous entend pas ma chérie mal
mais ça alors prenez un micro un micro
pour la jeune fille s'il vous plaît
comme ça en voilà mais ce qui vous plaît
merci en tout cas
je suis qui va du mondial de la coiffure
c'est presque pas sa chérie mais moi ma
chérie qu'est-ce qui se passe tu a
déchiré sa carte en fait ils déchiré ma
carte j'ai déchiré ma carte là des
lecteurs ouais on vient vite et je vais
te dire la vérité j'en ai trois des
stars telles que merci on est trois
déclare c'est bon là on entend c'est le
ses leçons cathédrale ok pas de problème
chez gm déchiré ma carte parce que tu
sais quoi là moi je suis énervé par la
coi à ces élections pourquoi des mois
pourquoi voilà avancé fois son prénom
déjà c'est quoi ton moi je m'appelle à y
soit allé ça voulait tout monaco jean
bref
c'est quoi ça sert mais toi tu
t'inquiètes pas ici laissez vous aller à
l'essai au super ne les remets toi
comment tu t'appelles machine alors avec
moi tu es énervé parce que parce qu'ils
travaillent mais c'est intéressant de
voir parce que on a personne qui a eu
cette réaction tourner la page au sort
donc ta réaction limitée est
intéressante dis moi pourquoi moi je
suis pas réalisatrice de s'il savait pas
où il va supprimer tout le monde
effrontée tout le monde a son mot à dire
donc c'est me retenir mais moi je suis
énervé je vais dire tu as voté clippers
jean luc mélenchon non je suis patient
et jean luc mélenchon je t'avoue
vraiment je savais pas pour qui voter
ici votez blanc s'était dit là bas tant
ok on voit les droites énervé alors
parce que je suis énervé parce que en
fait je vais t'expliquer un truc moi
j'ai écrit à plein de personnalités
politiques j'ai écrit à hidalgo
[Musique]
hidalgo pour ne rien de vu
cette puce est envoyé un devis de
travaux à la ferme où je vais voir
attention le placoplâtre à 4,95 à ça va
quoi au plus bas pour aller vite pour
être les témoins pour moi que je te
prennent tout ton temps sept mois si tu
as bien marquées chez une personne en
situation de handicap quand tu vois ça
fait 14 ans que je réclame mon droit à
l'accessibilité par ailleurs un logement
sûr pas raison ça fait quatre ans j'ai
fait plusieurs procédures judiciaires
par rapport à ça et tu vois on va pas
avancer enfin quand tu sais rien j'ai
écrit au maquereau j'ai écrit trois fois
macro il m'a répondu de une fois pour me
dire qu'il a bien reçu ma lettre tout
bord des passagers écrit à brigitte
macron pareil je me suis dit bon
peut-être ça va marcher rien du tout
j'ai créé à plein personnalités
politiques tu vois concernant les lois
sur l'accessibilité du handicap en 2005
il ya une loi pour rendre accessibles
tous les transports en commun tout fait
en 2024 déjà ils ont repoussé de deux à
savoir parce qu'ils ne l'ont pas
toujours pas été là et après maintenant
ils ont repoussé encore jusqu'à 2000
comme il à 2020 2021 2022 on sait même
pas alors donc très énervé pour ça non
je te réserver pour ça parce que là moi
j'ai pour moi très énervé sur le
résultat des élections parce que je vais
dire parce que y'a rien qui se passe tu
vois la gauche elle chiale elle chiale
elle chiale elle est complètement
effondré la gauche comme disait poutou
les candidats de la gauche pas les
candidats les électeurs de la gauche les
militants de la gauche eh ben ils sont
orphelins parce que tu vois la gauche on
a beau voter pour eux
leur était aussi et tout ça parce que
des fois on a besoin d'elle que des fois
on a des projets dit non mais voilà en
fait je vais tenir là le truc c'est que
aujourd'hui voilà la gauche c'est oui
mais c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas de la
faute des autres que la gauche c'est la
gauche et tutsis basse si c'est de la
faute à la gauche elle-même
ça
coûte en tout cas tu es pas il n'était
pas content tu me va très bien en tout
cas on combat lorsqu'il verdez aussi
desprat content parce qu'il est debout
merci d'avoir ce commerçant
[Applaudissements]